[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a japanese action film
called sailor suit and machine gun
graduation
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
izumi hoshi is a 16 year old senior in
high school a few years ago she used to
be the boss of a powerful criminal
organization called yakuza she was known
for ambushing a rival yakuza group with
her signature machine gun currently she
is the manager of a coffee shop owned by
three of her trusted gang members madoka
yuji and haruo they are trying to live a
normal life after retiring from the
criminal world but the coffee shop is
not doing well financially the three
former gangsters are still not
accustomed to their lives as civilians
but izumi binds them together and
supports them one day they are
approached by a high school girl
complaining about a modeling agency the
agency has been recruiting young girls
and collecting an absurd amount of money
from them they also ask the girls for
sexual favors in turn for a contract
hence she wants the group's help to shut
the agency down it is clear that
although the group has left the gangster
world behind the gangster life has not
left them yet the very next day they
barge into the agency and threaten the
manager to return every girl's
enrollment money the manager reveals
that the money goes to their rival gang
hamaguchi the gang is way more powerful
than them hence messing with it will
only cause trouble the manager smugly
tries to call the gang leader but yuji
attacks him izumi stops everyone before
things get out of hand and retreats for
the time being on their way back home
the group discusses the ways to get the
agency in trouble with the law now that
they cannot stop it by force suddenly
members of hamaguchi's gang knock out
haruo and yuji and request that izumi
come with them she agrees instantly
claiming that she also has a lot to say
to their leader hamaguchi upon reaching
their headquarters she walks in with no
doubt or fear even while being
surrounded by armed men twice her age
hamaguchi shows her packaged marijuana
cookies and accuses her of selling them
on neutral ground they made a pact long
ago where both parties agreed to stop
all the illegal selling of goods in
certain parts of the city izumi denies
being associated with anything of such
sort and asks him about the corrupt
modeling agency to her surprise
hamaguchi insists that they do not
support any modeling business the two
solve their differences but izumi
suspects someone is trying to drag her
down by spreading false information
madoka then arrives at the hideout with
firecrackers attached all over his body
to save his boss izumi returns home with
him deciding to investigate the matter
the next day then we are introduced to a
budding entrepreneur and the antagonist
of the film yasui his assistant shows
him a video of izumi and her people
threatening the modeling agency manager
it is clear that he is the one behind
the conspiracy and the one trying to
hide his illegal work using hamaguchi's
name his assistant tells him about the
history of izumi's gang when izumi was
in middle school her only mentor was her
uncle yakuza the former leader of the
gang one day he was killed by a rival
gang while bringing izumi home from
school following the death izumi was
made the leader and given the task to
avenge her uncle's killers she did her
job efficiently and ended the rival
group in an ambush before she disbanded
their gang she and hamaguchi made a pact
to never interfere with each other's
business which included several points
one of the points said that none of the
gangs are allowed to sell illegal stuff
on the shared ground back in the present
izumi and her group do some digging
around the neighborhood and find the
youngsters who sell the cookies they
pretend to be customers and discover
that the hamaguchi gang is the one
supporting the youngsters while the guys
believe that they are being cheated by
hamaguchi something seems fishy to izumi
she suggests they call the police and
let them know what is going on but the
police couldn't care less then we see
yasui talking to his right-hand man stan
who is also a professional assassin he
is informed about izumi taking an
interest in their business it is clear
that under hamaguchi's name yasui has
been selling illegal stuff and
supporting the modeling company
hamaguchi's right-hand man is named
tsukinaga he also suspects that yasui is
the one behind the miscommunication
hence he sends a spy to find out what
exactly is going on the informer
confirms that yasui and his company are
trying to take over their town after
doing the same to other cities over the
past few years yasui's main aim is to
make his partner win the upcoming
election and get him to be the mayor of
the town then after defeating the
gangsters they want to build
developmental projects for their own
benefit the same day izumi is at school
when a girl creates chaos by screaming
and running down the hallway when a
crowd gathers to watch her she runs
outside and is hit by a boss izumi
notices a packet of special cookies on
the accident spot confirming that she
was under the influence of illegal
substances on her way back home izumi
sees kusakabe a candidate for the city's
mayor who is secretly working with yasui
he is yasui's free ticket to take over
the town's politics and ultimately the
town itself izumi knows this but cannot
do anything because people trust
kusakabe and his false promises to make
the town better at night yasui and his
henchmen get the information that
hamaguchi is vulnerable because most of
his gang members are out of town taking
the opportunity he barges into the
gang's headquarters and offers hamaguchi
a deal if he kindly cooperates and steps
down as the leader of the gang he can be
yasui's partner and if not he will be
killed instantly after a lot of thinking
hamaguchi accepts the offer however his
right-hand man tsuki naga is not happy
about the deal he knows that if yasui is
left to rule the city he will destroy it
for his own benefit hence he decides to
take izumi's help to end the matter once
and for all he calls her to a love hotel
to talk in secrecy and shows her the
news about yasui's associate kusakabe
winning the election this means he is
now the mayor of the town and yasui has
gained complete power over it tsukinaga
asks for izumi's help to turn the matter
around but she refuses to cooperate with
him after all he is a trusted member of
the rival group before leaving tsuki
naga reminds her that her uncle kept her
in charge of the town and it is her duty
to save it from people like yasui medaka
who has also been listening to the
conversation follows tsukinaga outside
and asks him to stay away it is revealed
that tsuki naga was the one who killed
izumi's uncle but everyone has hidden
the fact from her until now the next day
izumi comes home after school to find a
crowd of people protesting outside their
coffee shop they believe that the shop
is a ruse to sell special cookies to
teenagers and must be closed when madoka
tries to restrict the protesters he is
arrested and thrown in jail by the end
of the day the place is in shambles with
no hope of the coffee shop's revival
izumi calls sukinaga and agrees to help
him in his mission yuji and haruo arrive
home from a trip to see izumi sitting in
the middle of the destroyed shop she
asks them to go away and do whatever
they want on their own however the guys
are adamant about sticking by her side
no matter what they cheer her up and
promise to take revenge on whoever
spread the false rumor the next day
tsukinaga and izumi go to find the
youngster who is selling the special
cookies they find him in the movie
theater and threaten him to reveal the
truth the guy discloses that he was
asked to sell the cookies by a man with
a scar on his face tsukinaga instantly
recognizes the unnamed as the assassin
stan who is also yasui's right-hand man
before the guy can give them more
information two masked men attack him
they have been sent to kill the guy so
he wouldn't sell their secrets to anyone
izumi and tsukinaga managed to run away
but the guy is killed in the encounter
the duo runs for quite some time in the
rain before they reach a storage place
that belonged to izumi's uncle tsukinaga
changes into dry clothes as izumi
watches him from behind she is intrigued
by his back tattoo that looks a lot like
her uncles did they talk for a while and
tsukinaga reveals that he knew her uncle
pretty well but before he can explain
how yuji and haruo barge in informing
them of the modeling agency manager's
death it is clear to them that yasui is
removing any possible suspect that can
lead them to him izumi gets up and
announces that their gang has been
resurrected and will be in motion to end
yasui yuji and haruo are overjoyed as
they had been bugging her to resurrect
it since the day they disbanded in the
following scene tsukinaga and izumi
barge into a club hamaguchi yasui and
all his gang members are also in the
club izumi ignores all of them and walks
to the stage before announcing that her
gang is back in action when yasuy laughs
at her and claims that no one cares
about her stupid gang she shows him
graphs and charts of every illegal thing
he has done in the town including the
date and time of when he sold the
special cookies to teenagers if the
reports get to the media the mayor's
involvement could be suspected and all
the progress they have made will go to
waste she throws the files at yasui
asking him to take his business
somewhere else but he calls her out for
threatening him with fake reports as she
could have never found the real ones
this quickly seeing that her lie has
been caught izumi panics at the same
time haruo and yuji who were outside are
brought to the club and held hostage
yasui puts a rope around izumi's neck
and drags her to the stage threatening
to hang her to death tsuki naga asks the
gang leader hamaguchi to say something
because only he can stop this now but
when the man stands up to protest he is
shot dead by yasui he mocks izumi and
reveals that tsukinaga was the one who
killed her uncle in a fit of rage
tsukinaga retaliates and a shootout
ensues between the two groups after a
long and hard battle haruo sacrifices
his life to cover their group and helps
them flee in a car izumi cries mourning
the death of her close friend and asking
yuji to turn the car around a few hours
later yuji stops the car and falls on
the ground revealing that he had also
been shot izumi insists that they take
him to the hospital but tsukinaga knows
if they turn back all of them will be
killed hence they drive to a forest and
bury a now dead yuji izumi confronts
tsukinaga about her uncle's death to
which he replies that he was ordered to
do it he had no choice because of the
business they are in izumi makes a fuss
out of it so he hands her a gun and
urges her to shoot him if she cannot
forgive him however izumi cannot bring
herself to do so following that the duo
secretly returns to the storage place
again after years izumi brings out her
machine gun ready to avenge haruo and
yuji's deaths madoka also escapes from
prison and joins the two on the mission
they go to yasui's company headquarters
and find stan outside tsukinaga fights
him and stabs him to death after a
fierce battle following that the trio
simply walks into a meeting between
yasui the mayor and their associates
yasui loses his temper and asks them how
they got in izumi doesn't back down and
fires at the group at random tsukinaga
and madoka join killing everyone else
but yasui but then madoka gets shot in
the arm and is injured seconds later
yasui fires at azumi but tsuki naga
takes the bullet for her with both of
those close to her on the floor izumi
freezes yasui walks towards her butt is
shot by madoka before doing her any harm
with a final attack tsuki naga finishes
him before falling into izumi's arms he
calls her beautiful with his last breath
as she kisses him in the end she and
madoka walk outside the building when
the police arrive madoka turns himself
in and saves her
a few months later izumi visits
tsukinaga's grave and tells him that she
and madoka keep in touch through letters
she has also given haruo a proper burial
and hopes that he found peace her life
has returned back to normal she still
owns the coffee shop that makes her just
enough money in the last scene we see
izumi graduate high school she sings a
song in the memory of the people who
died to save her
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching